Speaker 1: So South Dakota Trumpian Republican
Governor Kristi Noem was on CNN over the weekend
and she was asked, hey, you know, we have this
situation in Ohio, not that far from South Dakota,
where a ten year old girl is now pregnant. And she
can't get an abortion in Ohio because of the Ohio
anti-abortion bill. So she has to go to
Indiana. And Dana Bash from CNN asks Kristi Noem
what is going to happen in South Dakota
if this ten year old were in South Dakota?
Would she be forced to carry the baby to term?
Now, of course, implicit in the question is or
procuring some kind of unsafe so-called back
alley abortion and I don't even really like
the term back alley because it sort of like
puts shame to it. But I think what we mean is
like a non medically supervised abortion of some
kind or is she going to have to leave South Dakota
if this happened? Because that's really what
it is. And Kristi Noem essentially says, yeah,
that's what would happen. Check this out.
Speaker 4: They ask you about that. The
Indianapolis Star is reporting that a ten year
old girl in Ohio, who is six weeks and three days
pregnant now has to travel across state lines to
Indiana to receive an abortion. So I just because
this is a trigger law that was passed before you
became governor, I want you to be clear. Well,
the state of South Dakota going forward, force a
ten year old in that very same situation. Right.
Have a baby. It is, I think is incredible,
Dana, in this tragic story because I heard
about this last night. What's incredible is that
nobody's talking about the pervert, horrible and
deranged individual that raped a ten year old.
Speaker 1: Well, but. Oh, whoa. That's exactly
what I just said. Of course, we want to talk
about that. But the girl is now pregnant,
and this is a delay tactic. Let's spend three
weeks talking about the perverted individual who
did this so that it becomes even more difficult
for the ten year old to terminate this pregnancy.
This this is what they do. I just said
this is exactly what they plan to do.
By the way, remember, the question
is, if this was in your state,
Governor Noem, would this girl be forced
to birth this baby? And so far, we haven't
gotten to know. That means that the answer is yes.
Speaker 4: And what is it? What are we doing about
that? I agree with you doing this. And course,
that's a that's that is an important discussion
to have this that's an issue that the Supreme
Court has weighed in. Listen. And as we understand
what we can do for that little girl. I think we
also need to be addressing those sick individuals.
That's to our child. I couldn't agree more. Our
bodies are our bodies. And women are the ones who
who get pregnant. And in this case, it wasn't a
woman. It was a girl. Right. Should I have to have
a child? A child? Should she have every single
life? Every single life is precious that this
tragedy is horrific. I can't even imagine I've
never had anybody in my family or myself gone
through anything like this. I can't even imagine.
Speaker 1: But guys, she's saying the ten year
old in South Dakota would be fourths forced to
carry the baby to term. That's what she's saying.
Speaker 4: In South Dakota. The law today
is that the abortions are illegal except to
save the life of the mother without a ten
year old girl having to have a baby. No,
I'm never okay with that. In fact, that story
will keep me up at night. It absolutely will.
Speaker 1: She'll stay up thinking about it. She's
not okay with it, but it's what the law is for.
Speaker 4: A mother to have an exception
in a situation like that. A one got a one
year old little granddaughter named Miss
Addie. I can't even imagine. What I would
say is I don't believe a tragic situation
should be perpetuated by another tragedy.
And so there's more that we've got to do to make
sure that we really are living a life that says
every life is precious, especially innocent lives.
Speaker 1: Guys, she's saying that the answer is
yes. I understand that. She's saying yes. In
South Dakota, abortions are illegal except to
save the life of the mother. If the life of the
mother, who in this case is a ten year old girl,
is not endangered by the pregnancy, she should
not and would not be allowed to get an abortion.
That's that's what she's saying. This is the
country under Republicans like Kristi Noem. There
is no other way. To explain it. There is no other
way to sort of mitigate what they are saying. Yes.
In South Dakota and in every state.
If Kristi Noem got her way, if whoever
get their way, ten year old girls would be forced
to carry pregnancy to terms. Think about that.